er wandert täglich auf dutzende
kilometer durch eis und kälte
der polarfuchs temperaturen von bis zu
minus 70 grad kann er aushalten sein
dichtes fell gilt als eines der wärmsten
im tierreich
doch genau das macht ihn auch zu einem
begehrten objekt tierschützer unterwegs
in finnland ihr ziel einer pelzfarm sie
machen videos von polar füchsen in
käfigen die mit ihren artgenossen in
freier wildbahn nicht mehr viel
gemeinsam haben
[Applaus]
auf den bildern sieht man sehr oft dass
die tiere unter augenentzündung nein das
liegt vor allen dingen an dieser neuen
zuchtformen also die finnischen
pelzfarmen haben eine neue zuchtlinie
entwickelt und bezeichnen diese fixe
auch als sogenannte monster füchse denn
diese tiere haben mittlerweile die
fünffache gewicht entwickelt so dass sie
von ursprünglich drei bis vier kilo ist
um die 20 kilo wiegen große
übergewichtige füchse bedeuten mehr pelz
das extreme übergewicht hat
schwerwiegende auswirkungen
das belastet die gelenke gerissene
bänder oder sehnen können die folge sein
oft reizen die übrigen hautfalten auch
die augen das kann zu entzündungen
führen
ludwig maximilians universität münchen
wir zeigen die bilder der
veterinärmedizinerin elke rauch sie
kritisiert die haltungsbedingungen der
füchse die normalerweise einen enormen
bewegungsdrang haben auf pelzfarmen aber
in engen käfigen leben müssen den tieren
ist stinklangweilig und manche von denen
sind auch apathisch weil sie keine
möglichkeit haben sie sitzen die ganze
zeit auf peter boden haben keine
rückzugsmöglichkeit haben keine
möglichkeit irgendeinen anderen
untergrund als gitta boden aufzusuchen
haben keine möglichkeit sich vor
artgenossen zurückzuziehen
elke rauch erklärt polarfüchse auf
pelzfarmen kommen in gefangenschaft im
frühjahr zur welt anschließend
verbringen sie ihr gesamtes leben in den
käfigen nach wenigen monaten gegen ende
des jahres werden sie getötet
um ihnen dann das fell abzuziehen
die haltung von den füchsen auf
kommerziellen farmen kann ich nicht als
tiergerecht bezeichnen weil eben eine
sehr reizt erhaltungs umwelt gegeben ist
sie haben kaum bewegungsspielraum
und sie haben nicht die möglichkeit ihr
spezifisches verhalten auszuleben
vertreter der pelzindustrie
argumentieren diese füchse seien
speziell gezüchtete nutztiere die in der
freien wildbahn nicht überlebensfähig
sein
tierschutzorganisationen schätzen dass
jährlich zweieinhalb bis drei millionen
füchse in europa für die pelzindustrie
getötet werden es gibt keinen
artgerechten pelz den pelz bedeutet
immer für die tiere ein leidvolles leben
im käfig und deswegen wollen wir mit
unseren bildern die menschen eben
darüber aufklären dass sie in zukunft
keine echte produkte kaufen die
tierschutzaktivisten haben videomaterial
aus verschiedenen finnischen wildtier
formen gesammelt die beliefern auch das
finnische pelz auktionshaus sager first
das unternehmen wurde 1938 vom verband
der finnischen wälzt sich der gegründet
als vertriebsplattform
sager verteilt mit tierwohl habe die
höchste priorität in der pelz zucht in
vier internationalen auktionen pro jahr
wechselnd fälle von fuchs märz und
marderhund die besitzer im geschäftsjahr
2009/10 wurden 8,8 millionen pelze
versteigert was provisionen von fast 300
millionen euro entspricht
sager first wird dabei mit tierwohl und
gesundheit sowie ethischer und
nachhaltiger produktion den
zertifizierungs versprechen von sarah
versus im grunde genommen gar nicht zu
halten das sind leere worthülsen ist es
wird versucht dem unternehmen einen
grünen anstrich zu verpassen pelztiere
für sager first und auch für alle
anderen pelzfarmen werden immerhin
käfigen gehalten ihr gesamtes leben und
werden am ende brutal stromschläge
getötet
wir konfrontieren sager first mit den
vorwürfen
das unternehmen antwortet die
haltungsbedingungen entsprechenden
eu-vorgaben seien legal nach finnischem
recht und würden regelmäßig von behörden
kontrolliert darüber hinaus seien die
gesetzlichen standards weiter verbessert
worden
die maßnahmen betreffen zitat die
fütterung gute bedingungen für die
aufzucht das verhalten der tiere und
eine gute gesundheit
wenn ich diese bilder sehe muss ich
sagen als europäerin schäme ich mich
dass das bei uns möglich ist dass füchse
die normalerweise durch die wälder lang
um streunern er durch die landschaft so
eingesperrt gehalten werden oben unten
vorne hinten rechts und links gedacht
die ehemalige bundes
landwirtschaftsministerin renate künast
kennt die schwammigen eu-vorgaben für
pelztiere viel zu wenig platz für die
füchse schönheit und der wunsch ein
pelzmantel zu haben ist rechtlich keine
begründung tiere so zu halten und
deshalb bin ich dafür schon aus
tierschutzgründen dass wir eu-weit die
haltung von pelztieren verbieten
die pelzindustrie gibt gegenüber
frontal21 zu dass das übergewicht bei
den füchsen ein echtes problem sei dass
die farmer angehen werden die finnische
regierung will gesetze verschärfen aber
an der pelztier zucht festhalten
[Musik]